-Mr. Big Shot.
-[ Laughs ]
Came back to see us, yeah.
-Yeah.
-We missed you, bud.
I miss seeing you
every day, man.
-Yeah. You know, I've missed
everyone around here too, man.
All the guys on the floor
and the audience.
You know, definitely --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
The nurses, hair and make-up,
you know,
everyone behind the curtain,
definitely the band and stuff.
-Oh.
-Security.
All the security guys.
-Yeah, they're pretty cool.
-Yeah, I miss all those guys.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, welcome back to the show.
Congrats on "Black No More."
You not only wrote the songs,
but you star in it, too.
-Yeah, yeah.
-But you've been
working on this for years.
How long now? Six?
-You know, six, seven years,
I feel like, yeah.
-I don't know if
people understand how much time
goes into making these shows.
It is awesome, by the way, bud.
-Thank you. Thanks, man.
-How did you get
started on this?
Who told you about this?
-About seven years or so ago,
John Ridley,
who is the writer of this book,
and Scott Elliott,
who directed the show,
approached us
and, you know, said,
"You know, I know this is going
to sound crazy, but, you know,
we're thinking that you might
want to, you know,
embark on this endeavor
with us."
-Did they think it
was going to be a musical?
-Well, originally,
I don't think Ridley thought
it was going to be a musical.
I think he thought
it would be anything but.
So he -- After he exhausted
all options,
he's like,
"You know, I'll just --
I'll do a musical,
and why don't we get The Roots."
No.
-Honestly, it's some of the best
lyrics you'll ever hear.
And it's so much
and it's so you.
-I think it's densely packed
and I think the audience,
you know, is going to feel --
I think you'll experience
the full range of emotions,
so to speak.
You'll laugh. You'll cry.
You'll...
[ Gasps ]
You'll be surprised.
-Oh, there's twists and turns.
I mean, I know you've done this
now a bunch of times,
but to have these trained
Broadway singers
sing your stuff...
-Yeah.
-...how does that feel
to have somebody do that?
-It's surreal.
It's surreal for me, man.
It's -- You know,
I can't really explain it.
But I definitely have --
I mean, not that I didn't
already have, you know, just
the highest level of respect
and, you know,
appreciation for what it is
that people do in
the world of theater,
but, you know,
for musical theater
and people who are out there
every day, you know,
doing eight, nine shows a week,
it's just --
you know, just kudos.
You know what I mean?
The utmost respect.
-That's why -- But I also --
I love you're always
doing something different.
And this one is
definitely a game changer.
Do you want to tell
everyone what it's about?
-Yeah. I mean, you know,
it's kind of hard to nutshell,
but I'm going to try.
In short, the story
is about this crazy --
like, a mad scientist of sorts,
played by myself,
who invents a machine
called the Black No More device,
you know, through which
he's able to, you know, turn
black people white permanently.
-Yeah.
And, you know,
in his mind, it is --
you know, that's the answer
to the American race problem,
which, of course,
you know, it is not.
-Yeah.
-So hilarity and tragedy
and lots of drama in between.
-It's a genius concept.
The idea is great.
"I'm going to change
black people into white people.
If you want to be white,
I'm gonna to change
the color of your skin.
Yeah, let's do it."
And then you see what happens
if that does happen.
-Yeah.
-If that is an option.
It's funny. It's also tragic.
-Yeah.
-It's everything.
And I want to say -- I was like,
"Hey, let me know
whenever you want me
to come check you out."
And so I texted you, and you go,
"Come see the show.
You can come Thursday
or Sunday matinee."
You go, "Those are --
My understudies are there."
[ Laughter ]
I'm like,
"Dude, if I come see the show,
I want to see you in the show."
Why are you inviting me
to come see --
Those are the two shows
you invited me to
is the ones that you're not in.
-I know, I know. Yeah.
-"I'm coming to one of
the shows that you're in."
-Yeah, you got me.
-Yeah. I did get you, man.
And then I go,
"Yeah, let's go, man."
I thought it would be
a great thing.
I would come see you backstage,
say, "What's up, buddy?",
you know, "Miss you, man."
-Yeah, no.
Yeah, our paths just didn't,
you know...
[ Laughter ]
-No, it's not what
happened at all.
Our paths didn't cross.
I saw you,
hung out with your wife.
I saw your brother.
Michelle tells me to go meet you
on 41st Street.
-Yeah.
-I'm at the stage.
I'm talking to everybody
and I've got the mask on.
I'm doing selfies.
I'm talking about the thing.
I go, "When is he
going to come out?"
He doesn't come out at all.
Everyone else came out.
You didn't come out.
-Yeah, I exited on 42nd.
[ Rimshot ]
-I stood next to a dumpster.
-Yeah, you did.
You actually sent me,
yeah, a picture --
-A picture of me next
to a dumpster.
Yeah, I go,
"That's where I was."
Your wife wasn't there.
No one was there.
-That's very sad.
-But It's almost like
she told me where to not go
so that she didn't have to
hang out with me either.
-She knows what's up.
[ Laughter ]
-Dude, I was by myself.
I go, "You've got to be
kidding me, man."
It was --
Yeah, anyways, it was...
I didn't see that ending coming.
You know, that's another twist
and turn of my event last night.
-I didn't know -- It took
a while before I realized
that you were coming backstage,
because I didn't have --
Unlike, you know,
when I'm working here,
I can't have my phone, you know,
while I'm on the job, so --
-You have your phone here
when you're working here?
-I mean, yeah, when I'm here,
you know, I can do -- You know.
I'm over there,
I'm answering e-mails.
I'm online-shopping and
stuff, you know?
-Online shopping?
-Yeah.
-During our show?
-Yeah, FaceTiming with my kids.
We all do.
-[ Laughs ]
-You know...
-Unbelievable, man.
-Sorry to blow people's spot up.
-Hey!
-You know what, though?
When you come out,
you command the stage,
and the audience
is just, like --
and just eating out of
the palm of your hand.
It's just great.
You just know how
to do it, buddy,
and it's impressive.
And I even said this to you
in the hallway, too.
I said, "By the way,
the show has an intermission,
and everyone came back."
-Yeah.
-That's a good sign.
-That's telling, yes.
-I've been to plays where
you go, "I put in time.
I'll split."
-I think we've snuck out of
a couple shows together.
-But do you remember the first
time you performed onstage?
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
The first time I
performed onstage, you know,
that I can recall, I think I
was in the third grade.
I was in a talent show.
I sang, like,
a DeBarge cover or something.
It wasn't just me.
It was, like, me and
another couple of my friends,
and we lost.
It didn't work out.
So, I said, "You know, next
year, I'm going to come back.
I'm going to rap," you know, for
the fourth-grade talent show.
So I came back.
I was in fourth grade.
A couple of my guys were
still in third.
But they -- Some of them
have gone on to greatness.
You know, my original crew
for that talent show
was called the Crash Crew,
and the rappers were
myself and the emcee known
as Beanie Sigel.
-No way.
-Yeah.
-Beanie Sigel.
Was he third grade?
-Yeah, he was third grade.
-You're the elder statesman.
Yeah, you're like,
"I don't know if I'll talk
to these third graders.
I'm in fourth grade."
-Yeah, I'm like, "Come on."
-Respect.
-You know he was good
if I was socializing.
-Yeah.
Do you remember what you rapped?
-Yeah, yeah.
I remember I did, like, you
know, a speed-rap sort of thing.
-Could you give us
a little taste?
You know the way
this show works.
We always have a mic --
We always have a hot mic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know the way we --
Just a little taste of it.
-Okay.
♪♪
Look...
♪ Well, I'm a hip-hopper,
never-stopper ♪
♪ Rockin' all around the clock
a double "T" ♪
♪ You know it's me,
I'm rockin' on the M-I-C ♪
♪ The money-maker,
booty-shaker ♪
♪ Party rocker, non-stopper ♪
♪ Girl-taker, heartbreaker ♪
♪ Undercover super-lover,
debonair ♪
♪ I'm everywhere, Double T,
I can't be beat ♪
♪ Especially on the M-I-C ♪
♪ If you wanna challenge me,
well, take the mic ♪
♪ And I will beat a rocker
in a rocker ♪
♪ Make you want to
scream and shout ♪
♪ This beat is oh-so-fresh ♪
♪ Double T, yeah, I'm the best ♪
♪ Break-dancin',
pure romancin' ♪
♪ Always fightin',
never bitin' ♪
♪ Always write
and share the light ♪
♪ And rockin' on the mic
in the place to be ♪
♪ And I go by the name of
MC Double T ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Congrats on the show.
Couldn't be happier
for you, buddy.
You're brilliant.
Tariq Trotter, everybody.
Go see "Black No More,"
which is running now
through February 27th
at the Pershing Square
Signature Center.